in security footage obtained by fox news
and time stamped
monday 308 p.m pacific time
an 80 year old part-time napa resident
called nancy pelosi
can be seen slinking through a san
francisco hair salon
she has wet hair she is not wearing a
mask
but she was indoors she was almost alone
because due to chronovirus regulations
salons in san francisco
are closed for indoor services nancy
pelosi went inside
she can do that because she is the
speaker of the house third in line for
the presidency you cannot
because you don't have as much power as
nancy pelosi has the owner of the salon
a woman called erica kiosk was furious
about this she saw the unfairness of it
she told fox news that pelosi's trip was
quote disturbing and a
slap in the face to people who were not
allowed to work because of nancy pelosi
meanwhile our media was angry too not at
nancy pelosi
but at you for finding out it happened
over at politico a reporter called carla
marinucci
was incensed by this she tweeted and
we're quoting
have to ask upon seeing this is it
legal in california a two-party consent
state to videotape someone in a private
home or business without their consent
so it was the salon owner's fault maybe
it was a security camera's fault it was
definitely not nancy pelosi's fault
it was a setup and if you follow nancy
pelosi carefully you're probably not
surprised by that
after all nothing matters more to nancy
pelosi than cold hard science
observable facts are her lifeblood if
she hadn't been
born into a powerful political family
she might have been our generation's
isaac newton that's why you can trust
her when she says the president's
stealing our mailboxes and it's not safe
to vote in person and suppose he knows
what she's talking about that's the
principle that has guided her career for
decades now
and in fact if you watched msnbc last
night you watched her
point out and this is true that only bad
people
don't wear masks or stay socially
distant
what further evidence does anyone need
that this president doesn't care less
about the spread
of this virus than to see what he did
vandalizing by the way the white house
by bringing all those people there no
mask
no distancing and the rest he slapped
science
right in the face and what a bad example
that was
donald trump slapped science right in
the face and that's not easy by the way
because science is a worthy opponent
stings like a b but by that standard and
that is the standard now nancy pelosi
didn't simply
slap science in the face yesterday no by
not wearing a mask and sneaking into a
hair salon others were banned from
entering
nancy pelosi did something worse nancy
was he drowned science
in a 12 dollar a pint designer ice cream
cup she crushed science with her 20 000
subzero freezer and then she ripped
science apart like a state of the union
address and she did it all on camera